みなさんこんにちは
え
今日は一枚の写真から話を始めたいと思います
私が撮ったこの写真
ちょうど2年前の5月3日の光景です
今日と同じような五月晴れて笑い声が響いています
視線の先にあるのは当然
残雪の北アルプスを背景とした松本城天守です
この警官はなぜ
こんなに人を惹きつけるのでしょうか
松本城から望む常念岳の絶景
これには
3つがあったんです
2年前の4月江戸時代の古い地図古地図を10スロへの道を歩きました
着いた先のこの景観
先山まるで雷に打たれてい
この警官の正体を
直感したのです
私の中で儀式が変わり景色が変わった瞬間でした
嬉しくて眠れませんでした
そして私はここにいます
松本愛する全ての人とこの交付後
分かち合いたいのです
申し遅れました
私は生まれも育ちもここ松本
生粋の松元師です
この街は
祖母に手を引かれた散歩道ダルい
小学校に通った数が黒でありまた遊びがでした
そういえば高校時代にはちょうどこの画面の左スミ
堀のそばで
お城の鳩を捕まえたことがあります
食べませんでしたけどはぁ
いつものからかこの街の通りの一本一本がー
17世紀江戸時代の道筋とほとんど変わらないことに強く惹かれるようになりました
東京や名古屋などの大都市が戦争の空襲や再開発などで大きく変わったみたいです
ここ松本はこれを免れ400年前
白ができた当時の道筋を数を残しています
晴れた週末にご地図を片手にこの街を歩くことが楽しくなりました
松本は南北に長い城下町でその中心に松本城を置いています
ピンクは物資が住んでましょう
黄色は町人が住んでいます
青は寺と神社です
中でも赤く染めした場所は広い意味での城
城郭の範囲です
周囲お堀で囲まれ位の高い武士が住んでいました
また防衛上一般人の立ち入りは厳しく制限されていました
赤い線は当時のメインストリート善光寺街道です
白を返しながら
城下町を南北に貫くこの通りは
本町中町東町と続いた町2ノ町を今もほぼ同じ場所にたどることができます
青い線は髪を子田町しまう子達
かつて寺や畑もが立ち並んだこの通りは実に800メートルに及ぶ
直線道路です
道幅や紅梅も一定なまさに端正な通りです
私はこの街のたたずまい
まちづくりやの強い意志と優れた美意識を確信しました
日本の中央高地に位置する北松本が標高600メートル前後の山岳として
周囲を美しい山々に囲まれています
実はこの山も江戸の昔と変わりません
松本の西には北アルプスなり標高3000m 級の山々がつながっています
中でも常念岳は
松本台がの象徴的な山でその美しいピークがひときわ目を引きます
南に少し離れて学科座の乗鞍岳がそびえています
松本の東には美ヶ原と墓も市山鹿
まるで兄弟のような台形の頂を並べています
街を歩くうちに
この通りの街の通りのいくつかから周囲の山の頂めがけてまっすぐに
通りが伸びていることに気がつきました
それでは城下町をご案内します
城下町のきた御徒町です
この通りは墓ももし山に向かってまっすぐ伸びています
城郭内の東西の通り雨は講師です
この通りは美ヶ原に向かっています
城下町南の10人コーチ
この通りもまた美ヶ原に向かっています
城下町東ノリックスレ城下町東
江差待ちです
この通りはなんと40キロメートル先の乗鞍岳山頂めがけてまっすぐに伸びています
果たしてこれら山へ向かう警官は偶然の産物なのでしょうか
それではここでクイズです
この写真はどこの通りかおわかりでしょうか
少し寿庵の質問で恐縮です実は松本から遠く
320キロ離れた
山形県スローカーシュの通りです
この街もまた城下町の名残を今にとどめています
実はこの景観を城下町における
計画的な空間デザインと考える研究者がいるのです
彼らはこのような山などへ向かう超直線的な見通しの景観を
リスターと呼びます
私の主観に松本城下の家において
vista が語られたことはありません
私はどうやらそれを偶然に見つけてしまったようなのです
江戸時代周囲の美しい山々は日本亭における
借景として
意識的に利用されていたのです
無機質で人工的な都市空間の突き当たりに山の自然大きい
四季の移ろいを演出数
ここ松本は借景を置いたにはいわば
庭園都市だったのです
こんなこと自体私にとって大きな驚きでした
それと同時に新たな疑問が湧いてきました
一通り街を歩いた中に常念岳向かう通りがないのです
昔も今も松本の山といえば常念岳が主役ではないでしょうか
いやそうに違いありません
一月の山がいくつもの通りから望めるのに対し西の北アルプス
特にピークの名誉な常念岳の見通しがないのは企業です
主役の常念岳が城下町の演出から外れているとすれば
その演出家の腕を疑わざるを得ません
ひいてはここ松本が庭園都市であることすら
眉唾ものです
いてもたってもいられずにとりあえず白いの道を歩くことにしました
松本城天守は本丸に置かれそれを囲む二の丸
その外側の三の丸と合わせ
城郭を形成しています
それぞれが周囲をホリデー日生まれ
くろもん太鼓門ををてもと呼ばれた厳重なものに守られていました
したがって当時店主に向かうにはこれらのも全て無事に通過する必要があると思います
赤い線は記録に残る正式な城へ向かう道とジョールートです
とぞルートエイドと現代の知事に示します
並べてみると八十二銀行前の道路がクランクになっているのが当時の大手もの名残で
あることが一目で理解できます
あれた休日に大てもあとから
本丸黒ままでこのルートを辿りました
大手門から続く大名工事にやはり
常念岳のビザがありませんでした
青丸の中第一会館後は当時は外堀で今のようにしろに向かって直進ができません
東ニュー返して城を目指します
太鼓門を抜け二の丸に入り黒もを目指します
そこでようやく出会う
この合計です
そういうことだ
常念岳は
ここ二の丸に隠されていたのです
城主はこの山に
店主の借景という
最高の舞台を与えたのです
時の上司の搾油をが苦心しました
この警官は作られたもん
庭園都市は確かに存在したのです
思いがけない発見に鳥肌が立ちました
この瞬間私の中で意識が変わり景色が変わったのです
その後の数日間にわたる興奮から冷めて
果たしてこの発見が
本当のものなのかどうか
冷静に考えるようになります
私が今更強調するまでもなくこの警官は市民に愛され昔から大切にされてきたんです
とはいえ私も含め大勢の人が
山に囲まれた松本城の立地がもたら数
偶然の産物と思っていた節があります
なにしろ歴史文献のどこにもこの警官は殿様が丹精を込めた
空間デザインだーなどと書いてはありません
それではこの警官の作為性を
証明することは可能でしょうか
それから2年間
たどり着いた結論です
この景観をやはり
城主の絶景と呼ぶべき芸術作品だったんです
気づいたりは私がたまたまと上部とつまり
城主が定めた白いの道筋をお客さんの目線
来訪者の目線で歩いたことにあったらです
客に何を見せあるいは何を見せないか
と象ルートには城主の明確な人つまり
作為が反映されているのです
それを分析すると城主の狙いが見えてきます
物的証拠はなくとも状況証拠の積み重ねでこの警官への上司の関与が立証できるです
それではその証拠を示しましょう
実はこの結果には3つの秘密が隠されています
しろやまそしてしてんです
まず山の秘密からお話しましょう
とゾール土壌大名講師には
4カ所の交差点がありますが
いずれの場所からも常念岳のビスタワーを認められませんでした
これらの通りは常念岳の方向を向いていないんです
二の丸拡大図です
三の丸になかった常念岳の見通しはここ三ノ丸
赤い実践部分に至って初めて現れるのです
さらにねーなことに当時二の丸は高さ6メートルに及ぶ
ドルイット度塀で囲われていたと推定されます
想像してください閉鎖空間に取り込まれた
壮大な自然景観です
日本亭における借景のエンスーそのものです
常念岳は
店主の借景として際立たせるために外部からは意識的に消されていた
これが私の結論です
つまりこの常念岳の見通しは上ない唯一のものなのです
非常についてお話します
実は同じことが白店主の
言えるのです
先に述べたように
二の丸は高いドバイで囲われていました
つまり天使もまた
三の丸からは見えなかったのです
正確には見えたとしても上層階だけだったでしょ
意外なことに天使もまた外部からは消されていたのです
逆にとって待ちに待った店主の前後はここにの丸に至って初めて現れるのです
つまり
この店主もまた上な唯一のものなのです
視点の秘密についてお話します
この警官の客の視点
眺望の拠点はどこでしょう
図の赤い20万の場所
ズバリ死後の玄関です
この地点の後にも先にもこの警官はないのです
ちなみにこの先本丸には当時大きな5点がそびえており眺望は見込めないです
この警官の視点それは白の玄関です以上まとめます
じょうな唯一の店主
じょうな唯一の常念岳そしてそれが並んだしのの玄関
ここに現れたのは特別ずくめの経過です
この警官の作為性が見事にあぶり出されたのです
簡単に言いましょう
お待ちかね丸ごと点車
とっておき常念岳を従えてい
ズバリ玄関で思っています
やっぱりまいりますん
一生殿様にお供いたします
これが
この警官の
上司はこの場所で自分が客に値踏みされることを理解していました
それゆえの上司本心のもてなしの景観なのです
城主は客の目線を計算し尽くしたうえで白の原画に
珠玉の空間デザインをいたのです
己の術
k
権力
b 式を
この1点に封じ込めたのです
この警官はなぜこんなに人を惹きつけるのでしょうか
400年の時を経て人は今でも
上司の声無き声を聞いて
この場所に
立ちすくむのです
意識が変わると景色がかまず松本市民一人一人がこの壮大な作品に気づき
景色が変わると地域が買うそれを誇りを持って世界発信する
この松本は変わります
21世紀の都市の真ん中に17世紀の壮大な空間デザイン
つまり文化遺産がほぼ無傷のままで存在しという事実を
hiro 発信するのです
松本城下まちに浮かぶ天空の埋蔵文化祭
それはあなたの無意識の中に
埋もれていたのです
いまあなたの目にこの警官はどう映っているでしょうか
実は最後に残念なお知らせをしなければなりません
この警官の現状をご覧下さい
もちろん末悪気はありません
それでもこの松ちょっと邪魔かもと思って上がったん
意識が変わりつつある証拠です
をまずの子に料
持ち出したあなた
少し過激ですが地域が代わりつつある証拠です
意識が変わると景色中
景色が変わると地域が変わるんです
さあ
今から一緒に実践しませんが
はじめの一歩は
もう
おわかりですよ